foreign yeah I'd like to go ahead and
start this meeting of the legislative
oversight committee for improvement and
assessment and education
this will be the second meeting we've
had this fall we had the first meeting
in September and now we have the second
here in January I do have a and we are
being streamed for the public that's out
there knowing that we are being streamed
right now so uh in the future too we're
going to try to get for these smaller
subcommittee meetings uh represent
Cornell did you get a copy of the agenda
there
that's it yes uh we are going to try to
have a small subcommer our committee our
standing committee like this statutory
committee
um sit around the tables in the center
here so we'd be a little closer to the
public and so that's it's more of like a
work group uh although we do make
recommendations and we'll make
recommendations
um in looking at the agenda there are
copies on the table over there there's
the one sheet and then there's a couple
packets with everything that we're going
to be looking at today
um to begin with I'd like to introduce
the people that are on this committee to
my far right your left we have
representative Cornell she's been on
this committee she's on her second
committee I think this week yesterday it
was Career Tech education and and today
this and then tomorrow another and the
day after that another it's a busy
schedule and then we have representative
luno who is a member of this committee
um and representative Luna of course has
been here on education for years and in
this very knowledgeable of this area
that we're talking about next beside him
we have representative Miler who is the
past chair of House Education and is the
ranking uh uh representative
um and he is here today not as a member
of this committee he's just sitting in
and listening to what we're doing and
may participate but he's not a voting
member on this particular uh committee
and then we have representative cordelli
representative Cordelia is the Vice
chair of this
of the education committee and has also
been on education for a number of years
myself Rick Ladd from Haverhill
and to my left we have Senator Ruth Ward
Senator Ward is chair of the Senate
education committee and on numerous
other committees as well it's uh as a
senator you are you know obligated to
sometimes two three I don't know how
many committees standing committees but
uh it's quite a task we appreciate her
having the time today to come to this
particular meeting she is a voting
member on this committee
to start out on our agenda here so we
don't waste any time I just put as
number one and I want to refresh
everybody as far as what are the duties
of the legislative oversight committee
this is a committee that was reinstated
in the last year it had been eliminated
however this committee has some very
important tasks and reading through them
I'll do it very quickly these are
summarized these are not specifically
how it's stated in statute the
legislative committee shall review the
development implementation of school
performance and accountability program
that's that's quite a task in itself
submit an annual report that reports
submitted to the the Senate to the house
to the state librarian
um
Etc uh C proposed legislation that is
needed as a result of the review of the
progress and results of the policies
implemented under this chapter
so we are responsible for submitting any
new legislation that we see as necessary
or needed
D confer with commissioner of the State
Board the commissioner and the State
Board of Education to identify and
support improved school performance and
accountability so we work closely with
the department and with the State Board
he analyzed existing department of
education programs and initiatives which
support improved school performance and
accountability that's right down our
bailiwick right now that we have to be
addressing how we're looking at
improving where we are in our academic
programs and accountability for those
programs
received reports from the commissioner
regarding the status of public education
updates on the Improvement made by local
school districts towards achieving
satisfactory progress and student
performance so we receive these reports
back from the Department G review and
approve Statewide performance targets
developed by the Department of Education
and recommend to the legislative
oversight committee by the State Board
of Education so any kind of changes in
targets have to be recommended to this
committee and receive this committee's
approval
H we see reports from the State Board of
Education including rules recommended by
the department relative to Statewide
performance targets required under RSA
193 H2 and proposed legislation to be
submitted to establish such a Statewide
performance targets and state statute
during the legislative season session
review the unique pupil identification
system and propose areas within so
that's another area of dealing with
confidentiality of student records and a
Personnel working here
uh review the implementation and results
of the program relative to
accountability for the opportunity for
an adequate education established in 193
e so now we're involving ourselves in
1983e which is the adequacy section of
education and consult and receive
reports on such program evaluate and
review existing and emergent
performance-based measurement tools and
propose legislation for improvements to
the accountability program as necessary
K received security breach reports from
the Department of Education pursuant to
RSA 199 colon 66. consult with the
commissioner and proposed legislation
needed as a result of the review so
that's one area we've really not have
been involved with I hope we aren't I
hope we have no security breaches but in
that case this committee becomes
involved review and make recommendations
relating to academic standards and under
consideration by the State Board of
Education pursuant to 193e to a
column for parentheses C so there's a
huge task in itself that we review and
approve these academic standards so
today what I've asked under number two
here I've met just recently several
times with Dr Nate green Nate is working
over at the Department of Education he
works downstairs in dealing with all
this data and information and is a data
analysis and we hopefully we can give
them support this year with supporting
Aid and support through some of our
legislation but I asked him to come
today and explain to where we are and
try to Define and speak to academic
standards and the minimum standards for
public school approval there has been
some cons not some you know in the
papers you you hear of it concerns
regarding the the process which is going
on right now for the minimum standards
for public school approval at this time
Nate's going to just give us an update
where we are and try to help us Define
the difference between these academic
standards and the minimum Public School
standards public standards for public
school approval Mr chair yes could I um
could I make a couple of comments before
we start in with um Dr Greene
uh if it's no no just relevant to what
you were just talking about absolutely
yes absolutely so so thanks very much
Rick and and uh thanks everybody for for
joining us here this morning for our our
introductory meeting I'm glad uh the
chair read through the the duties which
are enumerated in the the statute that
establishes this committee but uh but I
think it's also worth
um just reminding the members of the
committee and members of the public
um uh some of the some of the language
from the Preamble which was the
rationale behind behind establishing
this committee and specifically and I'm
just reading from Parts B and C in the
uh in the Preamble of the of the statute
193 c8a and uh and it's it's very
interesting and I think it speaks a lot
to um to public schools in uh in New
Hampshire and and how we we go about
doing things but but it reads like this
respecting New Hampshire's long
tradition of community involvement
appropriate means are established to
provide an adequate educate an adequate
education through an integrated system
of shared responsibility between state
and local government in this system the
state establishes minimum standards for
public school approval and academic
standards for delivery of educational
services at the local level school
districts then have the responsibility
and flexibility in implementing diverse
educational approaches to instruction
and curriculum tailored to meet student
needs the next part concludes
and very importantly it says New
Hampshire's long history of authorizing
local governments in the form of local
districts to develop and administer
public schools pursuant to a set of
minimum standards established by the
state has successfully achieved on
average across the state and that's an
important thing on average across the
state high quality educational outcomes
thank you thank you very much now if you
open up your yellow statuary books which
we have the first statute there is
dealing with the shared responsibility
for education and list all those that
are sharing that responsibility so going
in here I welcome Nate could you please
help us out with the academic standards
and and with the minimum standards for
public school school approval absolutely
yeah so for the record my name is Dr
Nate green I'm with the New Hampshire
Department of Education I currently am
the bureau administrator for the Bureau
of educational opportunities which
includes a variety of different offices
one of those offices the Office of
Public Schools another one is assessment
and accountability and much of the work
that I'll talk about today
is involving both of those offices sort
of simultaneously there's a lot of
overlap and I think because of that
overlap there's Sometimes some
inconsistencies and there's some
conflation of what academic standards
are and what the minimum standards are
and part of the problem is they both use
the word standards and oftentimes in
education we just talk about standards
and so part of what I want to do right
off the bat is just make sure that
there's a clear distinction between what
we're talking about when we say academic
standards and what we're talking about
when we say the minimum standards for
public school approval
so the minimum standards for public
school approval are state regulations
they're found in ed306 and that full set
of Standards Define the minimum
requirements for a public school to be
approved in the state of New Hampshire
and it includes a variety of different
things things like nursing Services food
services janitorial services the
responsibilities of principals teachers
as well as the responsibilities on
districts when offering academic
programs and that's a key distinction
that I want to point out is the minimum
standards are relative to programs at
the various School levels elementary
middle and high school so they Define
what a mathematics program is required
to do at a middle school level for
example at a high school level
separate from the minimum standards we
have our academic standards in New
Hampshire we call those the College and
Career ready Frameworks they can be
found on the department of education's
website and they are much much more
extensive documents they are what we
would you know refer to as true academic
standards so for example in science New
Hampshire adopted the Next Generation
science standards those are the academic
standards that Define what a student
should know and be able to do at every
grade level K through 12 in science so
if you're looking at a third grader in
science the Next Generation science
centers are going to lay out a whole set
of standards for what that third grader
should be able to do by the end of that
grade similarly in high school if we're
looking at something like chemistry
there's going to be a whole set of
standards in the ngss that lays out what
a chemistry student should be able to do
at the end of a chemistry course and so
that's those are the the differences
between what the minimum standards are
which are relative to programs so for
example in science it might say that in
the science classroom you need to have a
certain amount of Laboratory space for
student safety the districts need to
offer certain number of science courses
but actually identifying what a student
should know and be able to do at a
really granular level is outside of the
minimum standards and those are the
academic standards that the state board
has adopted
and where those come into play separate
from school approval is that's what we
use to build our state assessment
framework so right now we assess
students in Three core areas reading an
Ela Math and Science and our state
assessments and those Frameworks for the
state assessments are built on the
academic standards that we've adopted
not the minimum standards and I think
there's Sometimes some conflation
between those two things but those
larger academic standards documents are
the the definitions of what students
should know that's what we build our
definition of proficiency on and that's
what we test our students on through the
state assessment system so I'm going to
stop there for a minute to see if there
are any questions
are there questions from the committee
at this time on on this point
so I will ask one then
um
if I ever open up 306 and look at the
area of art which is that you know it's
a curricular area substantive criteria
of an adequate education mentions art
and then it talks about the elementary
middle and high school
programs in terms of how art is uh
defined or are used it does mention
academic standards there in on now so
the
the the minimum standards for public
school approval is
you've mentioned a whole lot of elements
or components which are above and beyond
the ACT you know like like the the
facility itself like the the libraries
and all that but we we are talking about
subject areas and when we start dealing
with the this minimum uh standards for
public uh School approval we are also
then aren't we also discussing academic
standards
so there are parts of the minimum
standards when you read them that they
read like an academic standard and some
of them read a little bit like
competencies which you know teachers are
building competencies into their
instruction when they build a curriculum
for a particular course or grade level
the difference is the granularity I
think so if you take part as an example
the minimum standards uh it requires
districts to offer art programs K-12 and
it talks about some of the things that
they have to offer if they have to offer
opportunities for students to become
involved in artistic expression in dance
in theater in music
what the minimum standards don't do is
they don't say at a third grade level
students should be able to know and do X
Y and Z and art so it's that level of
granularity that exists in the academic
standards so we have National Art
standards that many of our districts in
the state use we have art standards that
we post on the Department of Education
website and those go really really
specifically into what should second
grade art look like what should third
grade art what should fourth grade what
are the types of skills that students
need to be able to know and do that
level of detail is not in the minimum
standards the minimum standard is going
to say you need to offer opportunities
and dance you need to offer
opportunities in theater you need to
offer opportunities in drawing or
painting things like that but what how
you actually build a curriculum you need
a lot more specificity and granularity
to build a curriculum to build out
lessons to have a progression throughout
the school year and much of that comes
from the framework that's in the
academic standards and not the minimum
standards
thank you yes representative Luna thank
you very much Mr chair um and it's sort
of a follow-up to um to your question
Rick and and thank you Dr Greene for um
you know discussing the the differences
between minimum standards and academic
standards I appreciate
um the now having a better understanding
of uh of where those differences are but
um could you talk I mean when you talked
about minimum standards you talk about
you talked about programs you talked
about services like custodial services
and and um and what the opportunities
the programmatic opportunities uh a
school uh would needs to offer it's uh
its students but I was wondering if you
could sort of reflect on where the
minimum standards um talk about the um
um you know what what I guess is
expected or what are the outcomes that
are expected from from a student's
um uh perspective and um and now that
particularly as as students you know go
into you know from elementary to a
middle school to a um to a um uh you
know Secondary School to to uh
graduation
um how do the minimum standards reflect
on on on things from a from a student's
perspective
so
it's interesting because there are
places where you can pull out I would
say you could read into the standards to
say you know these are going to be the
expectations we have on students and
what the student outcomes should be and
what we want and I think ultimately in
education that's our goal right we have
student outcomes as our final goal we
want all students to be proficient
across the subjects that they're taking
we want them to be ready for colleges
and careers when they leave our K-12
system but the minimum standards
themselves are a set of regulations that
were written primarily with a audience
of school boards and superintendents and
so when you read much of them it says
things like the school board shell the
school board shall provide or the school
board shall ensure and so they're more
programmatic in nature even though the
programs we're putting into place
through the minimum standards we have
certain expectations of what those
student outcomes are going to be they're
really written from the perspective of
this is what we're expecting the local
school board to provide to their
Community or to their students or this
is what we expect a teacher to provide
through the course of implementing a
math problem program through the course
of implementing a science program so I
would say student outcomes are probably
more reflected in statute when you look
at things like rsa183h which is the
accountability system and that's where
we talk about things like performance
targets that's where we set uh
short-term and long-term goals for
student achievement on things like math
and reading and Ela sort of separate
from the minimum standards but the
minimum standards really set out what is
what's the minimum academic and
educational program that we want to
offer our students that really reflects
a high quality education in New
Hampshire
thank you so I'll follow up to that
um if I'm looking at 193h
and I see the
uh title of some various thing called
performance standards for level one
level two level three level four
um so that performance standard let's
say a one or any of them is reflective
of where on the Spectrum
for the academic standards in that
subject area or that substance area of
criteria area
yeah you see the the to me I'm I see
them overlapping somewhat here and I I
don't know if I'm seeing it correctly or
not there's so there's a little bit of
an overlap and I and almost in the way
of a hierarchical system so the minimum
standards as a document of study
regulations tele District you have to
offer math and you have to offer math
K-12 every year you know the high school
level students need to take four years
of math here's a number of courses in
math that they're required to have by
the time they graduate they need to
reflect things like algebra and geometry
and then when teachers sit down or
principal sit down a curriculum director
sit down and they start to build those
programs they're generally not going to
the minimum standards because the
minimum standards say this is what you
have to do but now as you build that out
we have the academic standards over here
that say you know in Geometry here are
the you know 25 or 30 Concepts that
students really should be able to
understand whether you know we're
looking at shapes or proofs or angles
you know if you if you want to know
about sine cosine and tangent within
geometry those words are not going to
ever appear in the minimum standards
yeah but we know that that is a crucial
part of learning geometry and
understanding angles and shapes and for
the record I'm not a geometry teacher so
if I try not to delve too far deeply
into that particular thing I was a
chemistry teacher so maybe I should use
those as examples
um
those academic standards are also what
we build the state assessment on so we
talk about proficiency when we first
built the current state assessment that
we're using now back in like 1617 we
brought in groups of teachers at the
different grade levels and we had the
teachers go through the standards so not
the minimum standards but the academic
standards that College and Career ready
Frameworks and they actually took the
assessment they went through each of the
questions and then they sat down with
psychometricians they sat down with
researchers that were part of the
assessment company that the state uses
and we determined what level performance
did students need to have on each of the
various questions and how many questions
and how what kinds of answers do they
have to provide in order for the
students performance to be reflective of
those academic standards and that's how
we set the level one two three and four
it was a pretty lengthy process that
involved teachers at all those different
grade levels throughout the state so
it's not something that's set for us by
the assessment company it's actually
something that we build through
collaboration with teachers in the field
that are teaching at each of those
different grade levels but the minimum
standards were not part of that piece of
it so proficiency and performance on the
assessments comes from those academic
standards and mapping back to those
standards not necessarily to the minimum
standards though the minimum standards
do require that we have to teach math in
our schools
representative cordelli
thank you Mr chairman thank you Dr Green
um
in addition
um to the level one through four
proficiency there are also State targets
for proficiency and am I correct and
those are defined as part of the Esser
state plan that is developed by the
department and stakeholders
yes yeah so one of the things that we're
required to do as part of the SSA state
plan we have to set annual Benchmark and
targets Statewide and we did that
through a
I'd say it's probably a little bit of a
logistical regression process where we
looked at when we wrote the state plan
back in you know 16 17 18 looking at the
past three or four years of student
performance and trying to project out
what were the types of gains that we
felt like were realistic to continue to
push student performance up uh now I
will say that was pre-pandemic so the
state targets that we had for several of
those years we ended up securing a
waiver through the U.S Department of
Education for so for the school year is
19 and 20 we had State targets that we
were you know going to meet we've
actually pushed all those targets out
now for two years and we looked at the
19 school year and the 20 school year as
just sort of being steady in terms of
student performance particularly because
we didn't run the state assessment in
the 1920 school year
representative Luna
thank you very much Mr chair thanks very
much Dr Green
um going back to the um to the academic
standards I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about how um how the
um uh the standards has as written are I
guess informed by um by other state
statutes like um like our recently
passed Holocaust studies and um and um
uh concepts of legislation
sure so we have a variety of different
academic standards that are all posted
on the website under the the title of
College and Career ready Frameworks so
there are standards there are business
education standards I believe they're
family consumer science standards uh but
the three that have gone through sort of
the really rigorous
um you know public Outreach and common
period and been adopted by the state
board are the math uh Elaine reading and
science standards because those are the
ones that were required to have as
Statewide uh academic standards for the
purposes of the state assessments so
things like the Holocaust and genocide
uh standards live within the minimum
standards we don't necessarily have
statewide academic standards that relate
to that one I think because it's
relatively new uh and two because we
don't have a state assessment and one of
the things we have in New Hampshire as
well is the state is required to adopt
these academic standards for the
purposes of having a test that assesses
all students equally across the board
however there's no requirement that
school districts actually really use the
standards that are adopted by the State
Board of Education so you know we
encourage them to because all of their
students are going to be assessed on an
assessment that is tied to those
standards but school districts are not
required to adopt those standards
locally they could choose to adopt a
different set of of state or national
standards if the local school board
chose to
and a follow-up yes thanks
um and so so going back to the example
of the Holocaust and genocide studies
you you said that that
that feeds into the minimum standards as
opposed to the academic standards
um and and so uh would would the
academic standards be then updated
sometime to
um uh maybe in the next round of updates
for a certain curriculum area
to include that subject matter
absolutely yeah and one of the key
differences here is that anything that
is enumerated within the minimum
standards is a requirement of public
schools you have to do it it is a state
regulation but if it's in the academic
standards again districts have the
choice whether or not to use those
academic standards to build their
curriculum or not so that's another key
difference between minimum standards and
academic standards one is a choice and
one is a state regulation so the
regulations around the Holocaust and
genocide studies require districts to
teach them and to include those
components that are within it we also
have statewide social studies academic
standards and there are aspects of
Holocaust and genocide content that is
within the social studies standards the
districts would have a choice whether to
use those standards or to adopt a
different set of standards that they
chose
so Nate a proficiency score on the
national
test assessment
indicates comp Proficiency in that
competency does that correlate to our
our standards here in the state
uh so separate from our state assessment
yes
um they should so there there are
different studies it depends on the
exams that we're talking about
um so for example we use at the 11th
grade level the SAT for our Juniors for
11th graders
um and so they're being assessed on math
reading an Ela through the SAT we know
that for example with the SAT there's
also comparability with the act so
students that are scoring a certain you
know level or score on the SAT for our
state tests will most likely score a
similar or comparable score on the ACT
so it really probably depends on the
type of assessment and the test that's
being given we've done some
comparability studies across subject
areas so for example a student that
scores a certain score on the math test
we know we'll likely score within a
certain range on a science test because
there's some comparability between Math
and Science there's a little bit less
comparability say between English and
Science and English and math
so so
if I'm a high school administrator and
I'm trying to set up the curriculum that
particular building with my staff and
with my community
and we decide that at the Freshman level
that we're not going to be teaching this
area of maybe U.S history or whatever it
might be we're going to do that at the
10th grade
and yet we assess using a national
instrument that may assume that you've
had that U.S history at the ninth grade
and so our proficiency may not look good
well simply because we haven't taught it
uh yet it's in the next year coming do
we run in that alignment problem between
our testing instruments and how the
locals have decided to set up their
curriculum because that is a local
responsibility
so there's in one area where we have run
into some alignment issues I think with
math and Ela we're good
um you know we part of the reason why we
assess in the spring of the junior year
is because much of what is on the test
is being taught across the state in uh
ninth 10th and the first half of 11th
grade so in in that respect I think that
assessment is a good assessment of where
students are at
um however with the science test for
juniors one of the things that we've
noticed is our current Science
assessment assesses students across
three different content areas physical
science life science and Earth and space
science but in New Hampshire the only
two sciences that are required for
graduation are life science and physical
science so Earth and space science is
not required for graduation and there
are some students that have not taken
Earth and space science
and there are questions about Earth and
space science on the science tests that
were given to them as Juniors so I think
that we if we really kind of dug deeper
into that data into those details we
would probably see differences in the
science scores if we were able to look
at students who have taken Earth and
space science in high school and those
students who have not and my guess is
there would be a disparity between those
scores we are currently working with our
assessment vendor to do some changes to
the alignment of our science test to
make it more reflect the actual
requirements on school districts but
that's more a result of state
requirements and not necessarily it you
know any actor that's you know a local
school district you know is changing
their curriculum that really is just
purely because what we require as a
state
yes represent Luna thank you very much
Mr chair so I wanted to uh pick on what
we were just talking about here a little
bit so Earth and space science again for
it for a for example so
um Can can you talk with us a little bit
about school districts that do
um
uh include uh Earth and space science in
their um in their science curriculum uh
and uh and maybe you know are are is
that most districts or some districts or
few districts and in the end how does
that play out on um on on our students
outcomes and what their you know
opportunities are for success
so this is one of those times where you
you do have an overlap between the
academic standards and the minimum
standards and you know with the science
test how they both come into play so all
school districts offer Earth and space
science the minimum standards require
districts to offer it what they don't do
is require students to take it so as a
student you have a choice and so some
students you know may take physical
science or freshman year they may take
biology their sophomore year and then
junior year they decide you know I
really want to go into the medical field
I'm going to take human anatomy and
physiology and maybe their you know
friend takes Earth space science when
they go to take the Science assessment
their junior year one of those students
is going to have taken Earth and space
science and one has not and so there's
probably going to be a difference in the
science scores for those two students
purely because of student choice and you
know no parts all districts are required
to offer it by the middle of Standards
but not every student is required to
take it thank you
um there was a recent article put out
um
and I'm reading from this which was
written this fall New Hampshire students
test scores fell during the covet
pandemic
according to 2022 assessments taken by
sample students 30 percent of the
state's 8th graders and 40 percent of
the fourth graders are proficient or
above in mathematics
I've spoken with you a number of times
regarding trying to track the cohort of
students in all our schools
to find out how that particular class
that's in the third grade then later on
another year fourth grade and tracking
that and to determine and a little bit
this goes a little bit to what represent
Luna was trying to say about
the are stating that there may be some
schools which are hitting it and others
not is this one way we can determine
that if we can get that cohort
information back I know we we're trying
to get somebody to analyze that stuff
for you and I know that you're shallow
in staff there but um
uh you know I'm concerned that we're
we're doing something that we've got to
look at and find out where our strengths
are why are they strong in certain
locations and maybe not in others is a
result of instructional staff is a
result of aspiration of the community is
that a result of supervision in school
leadership parent you know
aspiration I I don't know and yet we we
need to get our math scores higher and I
don't think it's necessarily just a
result
of the pandemic
that we were sliding in mathematics
prior to this
so I guess the question is you know will
that cohort information help us
understand where we need to really
address
some of our our support from the
legislature to help get that you know
level increased higher in stars to
achievement
yeah so that's you know we're a big
proponent of providing as much data as
we can to school districts uh you know
to your point I think there could be a
lot of reasons that live behind what the
data says you know whether that is
changes that need to be made and
instruction and curriculum whether it's
a result of particular cohorts of
students and the experiences and the
environment that those students are in
whether it's you know cultural shifts
within school districts changes in
administration we know all of that can
impact overall school programs and data
so we're in the process or we're in the
final stages of publishing a dashboard
that will live within our website that's
going to show that kind of cohort data
we sort of call them heat Maps but
essentially you'll be able to see a
table for each school that shows each of
the grades and their proficiency
percentages as they move through so
you'll see this class you know in third
grade had this proficiency here's where
that class was fourth grade the next
year here's where they were fifth grade
the next year or sixth grade and you'll
be able to see you know kind of a
straight line the Prof efficiencies for
cohorts of students as they've moved
through grades and we think that that's
going to be data that's you know useful
for schools and districts that are
looking at trying to identify what what
are the issues you know maybe there's
particular cohorts of students they want
to focus on or maybe there's particular
grades you know we know and not just in
New Hampshire but fifth grade and eighth
grade we tend to see larger changes in
assessment scores possibly as a result
of students moving from one building to
another building or coming to the end of
middle school so there are different
places where we know that if we have the
data and we're seeing changes in
assessment scores whether they're going
up or down we'll know where to target
specific resources for those students
I'm hoping by March those dashboards are
going to be published hopefully sooner
but I'm I'm saying March and then if I
can over deliver I will the beginning of
March or the end of March let's shoot
for the beginning well that's true for
the beginning that'd be great further
questions uh Dr Greene representative
miler
thank you Dr Green for being here
uh I'm aware that the 306 standards are
our rules are currently being reviewed
what's the status of that review sure so
there's a group that's been looking at
the 306 standards and have proposed some
revisions to that we have met with a
group of teachers we've met with a
couple of other stakeholder groups we
have several meetings coming up with
some of the professional associations as
well but right now they're just
recommendations and revisions to the
standards my understanding is sometime
in either February or March there will
most likely be an initial proposal for
the State Board and at that point it
will become a state board of education
process right now I'm working with
several of those groups to try to gather
input and feedback as to the types of
revisions that they want to see in those
standards follow it please yes and so
what's the procedure for the input from
the practitioners regarding those
particular standards
so I know that the the group that has
been working on it is hoping to start
scheduling some public meetings over the
course of the next few weeks where they
can generate public feedback as well as
some specific meetings with some of the
different professional associations like
the superintendents associations the
principal Association we've met with
some of the curricular groups so I've
had conversations with Extended Learning
opportunity Network as well as the
library media Specialists group they've
had some suggestions school counselors
group has provided some suggestions so
we're continuing to see public feedback
but I know that they want to hold
several meetings that are just going to
be open to General Public feedback as
opposed to targeting specific groups so
will there be General feedback prior to
the final finalization of those
standards going before the board yes
yeah and then once the State Board takes
up an initial proposal there's always
going to be you know public hearings
involved with that as well so there will
be additional public feedback and
opportunities my guess is that with
something as large charge as the minimum
standards most likely there will be
multiple opportunities for public
feedback is there currently a draft
that's available for review on the part
of the public I believe there's a draft
that's going to be made available very
shortly yes thank you
so if I schedule a meeting for next
month would that draft be available by
then my guess is that draft will be
available by the end of the week yeah
okay thank you
further questions did you meet this this
week yeah this week that's what I
understand this week
yeah so we're we're climbing up on it
that's that's uh that's good Rick a
quick question for you yes could um
could you uh get that
um as soon as it becomes available we're
going to request that a copy be you know
sent to us we can make multiple copies
here
uh but could you get a draft to this
committee as soon as it's released
absolutely yeah PDF and we can get it
out as well as the whole education
committee oh yes definitely yeah thank
you Rick definitely I got another
question it's jumping off this topic a
little bit
um there are a number of school
districts out there that are giving
their own assessments above and beyond
the Statewide assessment that which we
do
and that that might be the key math test
or some other test can you tell us the
difference between a formative and a
summative test sure yeah yeah I know
sometimes they use interchangeably
they're very very different so folks
like me within assessment circles you
know really try to set those two things
apart from each other because sometimes
people try to equate the scores on one
with the other
um and they're used for very different
purposes
um so the best analogy I can make when I
was you know still in the classroom as a
teacher I would give regular quizzes to
my students it would have weekly quizzes
and that was more for me as a teacher to
make sure that the instruction that I
was providing to my students was being
received and that I was actually hitting
the points that I needed to hit so if I
got a set of quizzes back from students
and they didn't understand half of the
stuff was on the quizzes I knew the next
three lessons I was going to give we're
going to be targeting that content that
the students hadn't got so formative
assessment are like those weekly quizzes
it's designed to help a teacher in the
the moment change their instruction
change their practices in the classroom
to make sure that they're filling gaps
in student learning a summative
assessment on the other hand is after
the fact it's designed to you know show
what a student was able to do after
taking a particular course or a
particular program and a good example in
the classroom of something like a
summative would be a final exam if you
get to the end of a school year and it's
the last day of the year and a student
takes a final that's not going to inform
the teacher's instruction you're going
into summer that's really a measurement
of how did the student do at the end of
the instruction so the state summative
tests are summative assessments they're
designed to measure what a student was
able to do by the end of a particular
grade so at the end of third grade
here's where students were at at the end
of eighth grade here's where students
were at so many districts will use
formative tools things like nwea Star
tests I ready many of those tests they
can give multiple times throughout the
school year and that really is designed
to Drive instructional changes during
the year to make changes so that you can
still provide instructions to students
before you get to the summative
assessment
we have some schools that are giving the
niwa or nwea or the the star star mass
star reading Etc and but the the results
on that uh summative instrument
and some of those tests you can give
mid-year too as well but and it's it's
Divergent then then the results we're
getting from the Statewide assessment uh
and so a school district may be given a
bad rap because here I have a slow
achievement score here but on our
individual Norm referenced assessment
test we're seeing are doing well because
we better aligned it to our our sequence
of curricular instruction
um are is that An Occurrence it's common
at all or existing in the State uh yes I
regularly hear from districts that you
know have local assessments that they're
providing that are you know giving them
one set of data and then their students
are taking the state assessment they're
getting a separate set of data and
they're saying why are students showing
this level of proficiency here but this
level of proficiency here sometimes it's
just a difference in in the assessment
structure oftentimes it's a difference
in when the tests are given and again
it's a difference in the the purpose of
the assessment itself health
thank you are there any further
questions
we have a little bit more on the docket
here so I I don't want to
um
not seeing you thank you very much Dr
Green thank you appreciate it and we're
looking forward to the end of the week
I'd like to you know I handed out a pack
of the materials here to all the folks
here on the on the committee here and
there may be a few people with packets
out there the next one down I had deals
with the areas of assessment
specifically history geography civics
and economics
which there's a letter that
um I I received from Mary Gile who used
to be the chairman of this committee
that I've included in that packet
um I'm trying to locate it here
but it speaks to some of the requests
here at us right here
um
and this came from from representative
guile
it's well it's not a it's about halfway
through and you can see it it was a
little review Senator Stiles
and at that point in time we had
history and Civics and economics as part
of the required assessment given by the
Statewide assessment but it wasn't being
given we were doing a science and
English language arts reading and
Mathematics so then it was the decision
of the legislature where we put into
statute that this now is responsibility
of the locals to assess the nature of
where they are with achievement in these
subject areas
my question is is that being done
and I'm not looking to the immigration
test either as being an assessment of
those areas of curriculum be it
economics or be it civics or being in
history
um so
yeah so
um I I I I throw that out there seeing
that this was a concern that was
generated way back in 2014
and
I'd like to know whether if we have
districts which have grabbed it and are
doing it or whether they're just leaving
it up to the local classroom to do an
assessment as we go along just like the
grade in your report card
so somewhere along the way I I'm yet I'm
just asking committee members now is
this worth pursuing or is it something
that we
just leave alone
you need to keep that question right
what do you want okay the the statute as
it reads right now I don't have it right
in front of me but the statute says the
Statewide
Improvement assessment test which we
give which is Statewide one is for those
areas of mathematics then we have the
science at certain grade levels and we
have the English language arts reading
that's it we used to have as a
requirement that social studies was part
of that however we didn't have an
instrument which was measuring social
studies achievement
so we recognized that and said well
maybe that's something the local ought
to be doing
so we did say but it's still a
requirement if you look at that area of
I don't maybe I it's in uh on Page Six
on page six page six of the C5
toward the beginning
yes there it is okay it reads
the Statewide academic areas to be
assessed shall include reading and
language arts mathematics and science
history geography civics and economics
remain required critical areas of study
therefore assessment of these subjects
remains within the purview of the local
school board
the Statewide Assessment program shall
only measure student understanding of
key content specific Concepts skills and
knows applied within or across academic
content domains and if you look back at
193e those academic
content areas include those subjects
that now we we hand it over to the local
school board to do my question is is it
being done
now we heard in the inaugural address of
the governor the other day that Civics
is a an area we want to pursue well we
should be
um so I
I'm just asking okay here and that's
where it's I put it out there should we
be trying to find out from school
districts what they're doing in regard
to this
so Rick I think that's a I think that is
a good question and and
I I believe
we heard last year or the year before or
the year before that um that the um uh
in particular I think the social studies
curriculum is something that the
department the state
um
um uh let me use the right term I guess
academic standard for social studies is
uh is a work
um uh is a work in progress right right
now and um and
the
you know maybe this is something that
that we could work with the school
administrators Association on to get uh
feedback from the districts on what
their what each district is currently
using
for a social studies
um you know using that as the as the
envelope for um for this question what
they're using for social studies
curriculum given that the uh that the
State draft is um is still in progress
would that be worth getting a poll on I
I think it'd be it'd be helpful for if
we could use for organizations such as
that or even right through the
department yeah does the department have
any information on on what's going on we
right in 2014 we put it down to the
locals now okay what's what's going on
uh it's it's something that I as a
parent and I as a legislator up in my
neck of the woods I have people asking
me you know what's being taught in
school and social studies now they want
to know that their child knows that
Brazil is in South America New Mexico is
not another state a country
and and in those are terms which used to
be in the Old National Council for
Geographic education stuff that came out
they had an assessment which was used
for that I that that's a long time ago
that's back in 1980s
so what's being used today I don't know
representative Cornell other than the
testing I don't think we even know in
what's being taught in each grade I I
think even in the middle schools in
Manchester if I can remember sixth
seventh and eighth grade eighth grade
was always U.S history but sixth and
seventh taught different things at
different times and different cultures
and you know one might have South
America and then they'd do Mexico in the
the next grade so it's
we don't even know that no it's it's
changed we used to use the old textbook
models where you start out with
Community my my family my neighborhood
my community and then by fourth grade
usually in the State history State
Geography and then you move on to U.S
who I don't know what's going on
nowadays and um I think it's worthy
worthwhile to try and ask that question
yes I I think I think it's worth
pursuing the question is can you get the
data well that's the question uh I mean
that's always the question well I mean
yeah as we have found I mean in the uh
teacher shortage uh work study work
group uh we it was even harder for
superintendents to get data back on what
the status of that was and so I think
the the school districts are inundated
with requests
to get information and so it's hard to
get that information back perhaps it
might even might be easier
to use the social studies teachers on
this particular topic ask that group if
they could get the information from
their peers rather than going through
this through the school district so I
don't know I mean just the Gathering of
the data is difficult I agree
representative Myler there is a social
studies group within the state we could
always work with them as well I'm open
to trying to work with any group that
can provide us more information there
was a study at the department going on
but that was disbanded
so now we are sort of this area of flux
on this subject area and what we're
going to do we're going to end up
waiting for the national to do something
and then lo and behold here we are once
again developing our curriculum around
some kind of a national proficiency
level not what we see as necessary in
our own state
so I'd like to pursue that and try to
get as much as we can right
um Rick a quick question question to you
do you do we know where the um where the
um the department is in terms of
development of the social studies
curriculum I think it's been disbanded
that's just that's what I thought yeah
yeah so it is not there's nothing going
on oh okay I didn't realize that thank
you so we need to
if you give me the green light I will
start doing some questioning and asking
and get back to this group
do you feel about it okay
oh okay there's one other thing I'd like
to do here I know that it's it's 11
o'clock and this one is probably going
to take a little bit more time
uh item number four there was a new New
Hampshire State task force on
mathematics instruction
they ask you to report back in January
18th
2012.
that report was chaired by Paul leather
who was the Deputy Commissioner of
Education underneath Jenny Berry at that
time
and this report was a very thorough
comprehensive report from which we have
taken some recommendations
and we've gone and and placed them in
the statute one of which was to get
involved with the applying our skills
through stem and CTE programs we've done
that the fourth year of mathematics we
didn't go with the fourth year of
required Math course we went with the
fourth year of having math skills
embedded in a course in the high school
of which had to be approved by the local
school board and every student has to
take at least four years of mathematics
or three years of maths courses and the
one year of embedded mathematics
question I have is that being done it
goes back to that accountability thing
again and if we could all open up to
that report right here I'd like to walk
through it
and I've starred several areas which I
think are are critical and very
informative that was back done in 2012.
we're looking at our state proficiency
and math is going the wrong direction
right now
and for what reason I don't know and and
uh but we do see it in the news we see
it we hear it we saw it it's some are
saying it's all pandemic related but
according to this report it was going on
prior to that back in
2012. So on page five of that report
I've underlined
and this is coming out of 2014 it states
New Hampshire must reverse the
disturbing Trend poor mathematics
performance in its high schools and
minimize the need for remediation and
post-secondary institutions
jumping on here to the next page I
underlined
on Page Six
however that data in Figure 1 also
suggests the decline in mathematical
performance becomes evident during the
Middle grades 6th through eighth grade
that's where that this task force
started seeing the fall off
going on to page seven
we're in 11th grade mathematics
performances compared to other content
areas there is further data to suggest
that performances and Mathematics the
middle and secondary levels need to
become a priority for New Hampshire
for all grades tested by kneecap at that
time mathematics performance is lower
when compared to achievement and reading
that still exists
while the percentages of students
proficient in Reading seem to remain
consistent during grades six through
eight this is not the case in
mathematics
that was back in 2014 jumping further to
some of the areas that underlined
on page 11.
the presentation further stated that
approximately 65 percent of students
entering New Hampshire's community
colleges in the fall of 2009 tested not
ready for the first college level
mathematics course it seems this data
could have been predicted based on the
2009 kneecap and nape results which
demonstrated that approximately
one-third of grades grade 11 and 12
students were professional were
proficient in mathematics I talked with
the community college system the other
day we still have remediation going on
at the community college level I don't
know if it's that 60 percent level
that they're not teaching as remedial
math now they're working with the kids
in the classroom
and of course they cater to an adult
population it's older than the student
coming out of out of uh High School
moving on let me read these things off
then we can have a little bit of a
discussion on it going to page
uh 16.
the final component of instructional of
instructional change is the impact
teacher content the impact teacher
content and pedagogical knowledge and
attitudes about mathematics have on
student learning and achievement
teachers need a deep understanding of
mathematics they T they teach including
Concepts practices principles
representations and applications to
support effective instruction that's an
old study but it's surely true today too
that even our teachers in elementary
school have to take the Praxis in terms
of mathematics and some Bach against
doing that but I think it's absolutely
you know a good case for having to take
that
on page 17 based on Research relating to
effective teaching and Mathematics the
task force to improve mathematics
instruction
recommends pre-service mathematics
teacher programs and professional
development for practicing mathematic
Educators I think it should be for all
teachers
elementary through middle and on high
school are we doing it I don't know
um recommendation five
include training on how to effectively
utilize and incorporate 21st century
skills such as stem and CT outcomes and
Mathematics instruction to provide
students with opportunities to apply
mathematical understanding and authentic
context
with real world applications that was
the onset of the math learning community
program and using the accuplacer at the
end of the 10th grade which we no longer
fund and it's not being done
uh and what we also recognize that
there's different styles of learning and
different styles of teaching and this is
proposing that we we teach it in
conjunction with the skills that career
is going to be requesting them to do
later on
um going further here
there's a on page 23 you can look at all
the recommendations which came out some
are just great recommendations
on page 23 in addition High School
Mathematics Curriculum instruction often
focus on Mastery of conceptual and
procedural knowledge rather than on the
application of Concepts and procedures
linked to real world context
how true
and going a little farther and then we
can have if there's any need for a
discussion here on page 24
underline the goal should be to provide
support so that all students can reach
the College and Career ready line by the
end of the 11th grade ending their High
School career with one of several high
quality mathematical courses that allow
students the opportunity to deepen their
understanding the College and Career
ready standards that's why we integrated
the embedded mathematics in the fourth
year recommendation 17 there on that
same page include a study of mathematics
for each year that a student is enrolled
in high school for a minimum of four
credits and Mathematics for graduation
from high school that we didn't do
that we didn't do
it's three
we went with the embedded which is a
maybe a credit in social studies and
learning how to use the spreadsheet
number 20 on page 25 provide increased
opportunities for deeper learning
including experiences to apply
mathematics and real world contacts
connections will be made to Extended
Learning opportunities we had a
youngster in the other day with
extending learning opportunity that came
from your town their reps in luno
um opportunities utilize science
technology engineering Career Technical
education and relevant applications
lastly recommendation 20 include the
requirement of successful completion of
algebra for high school graduation
however future movement will be made to
ensure that all New Hampshire school
students are obtaining mathematical
content equivalent equivalent through
Algebra 2 to be prepared for a variety
of college and career opportunities we
know that that is not the case that
there's a number of students coming out
of algebra one who are you know just
unable to tackle algebra 2. and uh so
that was one of the things we were
trying to do with of course the bath
Dorian from the community college system
was trying to work with us on so
mathematics is sliding still
um
what are we going to do
or do we do anything or do that we let
all that Federal money in the schools
take care of it
representative cardelli thank you I I
think it's not just a New Hampshire
problem but according to nape it seemed
to be a national problem for mathematics
uh so I don't know
um
if there's a not uh National solution
um or a local solution
um but it's interesting that a number of
these recommendations also all uh
reference um we real world application
of mathematics is part of the rep uh
recommendation
um
so I'm not I'm not sure and to answer
your question where we go but I think
there are several uh pieces of
legislation dealing with mathematics
this year that uh will provide uh for a
good discussion of
uh where we do go I think I mentioned
the last minute I had a meeting with all
the math teachers up at Rivendell that's
a Interstate government uh District we
have between Orford and fairly Vermont
it's one of our districts and I had high
school middle school there and then I'll
mention there was not
one tune song they were all sort of like
going in different directions in terms
of how I teach mathematics
and based upon their background but
they're all very anxious to see their
their kids get to the point where we're
seeing that level of achievement we want
and working cooperatively together
is there a mathematics Association in
the state
that we could work with in terms of
trying to
is anybody out here maybe no Becky do
you know
so they're just not siloing it to middle
school but are they also working with
the elements a lot of kids get the fear
of mathematics right in the grade school
and from that point onwards it's it's
very difficult for them to really grasp
and especially if the if the teaching
style doesn't match up with the learning
style of that child
okay
yes represent Luna yeah Rick thanks for
including this because I hadn't seen
this report the leather report that was
very comprehensive and after that he
left for Kentucky yeah yeah and and you
know and obviously some of the uh you
know the data is um is a decade old but
I think the um the the issues that that
it raises are um are are certainly uh
you know contemporary
um but but one of the the thing that one
of the things you skipped over on here
and I think your review on this was
excellent on page nine figure four has
got me going here
um because it's the cohort map yeah
and and it's it's interesting because
um
it uh it it certainly tells the story
about about you know something's
happening in the um in the uh early high
school years where um where where you
you know the um the kneecap scores in in
this case sort of fall off a cliff
but in the Years building up taking a
look at the cohort that moves through
and you sort of have to look at it I
think along a diagonal going across the
the cohort map
in general the scores are improving
they just they just fall as as as as the
cohort goes into the more advanced
grades but across the years they um they
increase that's how I'm reading this is
that that's that's how it is right
across our country
and and you know I had it when I was a
school administrator and principal up in
Alaska we we saw the fall
start yeah at the end of the junior high
school
and and and then it went downhill
um so what can we do to try to reverse
that Trend and so yeah yeah well I I
think it's an there's an interesting
Dynamic if I'm reading this this this
graph
um correctly because looking at the 2010
um
uh uh 11th grade did better than the
2009 11th grade and they did better than
the 2008 11th grade and they did better
than the Tucson 2007 11th grade so there
was Improvement
horizontally but there was decline
looking at the cohort as they move
through the grades so there was this
sort of like General Improvement going
on but it but we were losing something
in that in that sort of 9 10 leading to
11 for for every cohort and see and we
have so many other issues approaching us
now that weren't existing back at in
this era it'd be great to get some new
data you know the social issues the
pandemic related yeah all that uh
families you know you know they probably
don't have dinner together they have it
around the TV set or while they're doing
XBox and and
um I'm I'm I'm concerned here and I look
forward to the data we might get back
from Dr Green here on following these
cohorts in these subject areas and even
getting down into the weeds not just
mathematics but getting down into the
skill sets and the knowledge in
mathematics so we can see that you know
it's it's expensive to replace your
whole curriculum in a school district
when in fact you may just have one set
of elements or themes which are needing
repair repair that not throw the whole
thing out with the with the wash uh
represent Cornell and then Senator sorry
how do these scores compare with how the
students are doing in their classes or
or you know on their you know
yeah I you know is there a are they
doing this poorly in their their high
school math classes or
are they just doing this poorly on the
tests
the kneecap test
it could be that's a good question as
you get older in school attitude towards
standardized testing falls off I think
from when you're younger and a classroom
teacher has the group of kids and says
okay everybody's going to be on time and
you're going to do well and you know and
but in high school they're doing it as a
big group and I don't know if it's given
the same way exactly do you think
there's any the other day I was talking
with my wife and I was saying about a
couple of our grandkids which are off at
college and graduated and some going
and I said boy you know
when I was in college getting an 88 in
in something was a real feat now the
kids come back and you know I've got A's
you know and so my 88 was that an a back
then compared to today do grades are
grades easier today than the yeah great
inflation I don't know what you want to
call it but uh when I went in as a
school administrator or principal up in
Alaska I looked at the report cards
after two after the first semester and I
collected them all and this is a school
of in elementary so it was it is
basically grades four through six and I
had about 450 kids in that school talk
to the report cards and the average
grade in the school was a minus
I said this can't be and so when I had a
teacher meeting I said that to the staff
and I said what's going on here I said
well the parents are kind of expecting
this and are you going to be there to
support us when we give what I said yes
you just send them to me we changed it
so a CU as a c
and by the end of the next year at the
same time things have been corrected and
and actually everybody's more pleased
parent-wise knowing their child was here
and it wasn't a false report so that I'm
not saying that's characteristic of
Education today everywhere but that
occurred where I was
so great inflation
representative senator
what I've heard many times is that to
like math is
it's a very esoteric kind of thing and
only the very smartest can go with math
and I think this particularly something
that has been told to women oh you're
not you know woman is not that that math
is not for you it's for certain other
kinds of people and I think
teaching math has had that with it
if you have an expectation that the kids
are not going to understand it
and they get that feeling they're not
going to be totally excited about it I
think Math is fun it's it could be done
in so many different ways of seeing how
math is in every single thing that you
do you see math problems you don't think
of it as a math problem but it is so you
have to know a certain level of math in
order to understand in order to function
so I think math has had a bad rap and
I'd like to see it promoted
foreign
yeah thanks I couldn't agree with
Senator Ward more on on this
um and I I had heard this at some ncsl
um
um uh work groups I I think I heard it
when I was on the school board too
um that uh that that certain groups in
our society were discouraged from from
pursuing math it's not for you and and I
think we see that in a lot of areas and
it's and it's why it's so important to
begin and address that and I I know this
is a hot word but it's an equity issue
and in with what with what Senator Ward
was saying it was an equity issue for
I'll use the word girls because we're
talking about you know
um you know Elementary and and secondary
school
um and uh where where you know everybody
is taking math and again I'm sort of
looking at this figure four they're all
taking everybody's taking math in third
grade fourth grade fifth grade sixth
grade and then you know something
happens
and um and and uh uh you know certain
certain groups are discouraged from uh
or encouraged to pursue something else
and not math and um and then you wind up
with the uh with the number at the
bottom in grade 11
um which which I think reflects that
that
um
you know that shift and uh and I I think
as a as a as a state and as a country uh
you know we can do a lot better when it
comes to making sure that uh that that
that that all of our all of our students
have um have you know strong
opportunities to pursue and succeed in
not just math but other you know areas
too and um and uh anyway I'll I'll leave
it at that but I think I thank Senator
Ward for uh for raising this
yeah I think Mr chair you've got your
answer
we need to pursue this okay I I think we
we will we will pursue it
um
talking to one of my grandkids who's a
freshman in high school this year and he
was saying I just don't want to be in
that art class sign me up for a science
or a math class he his brain it's
there's brain research out there now
that uh we need to be looking at uh he
he was saying I can do well on that but
I I don't get this other side and I have
another one that's up at St Lawrence
University in the same domain it's his
Forte is statistics and and all the
spreadsheets and and business
when it came to have to know something
about the Sistine Chapel he didn't want
to know a thing about it
and unfortunately that's not kind of a
narrow focus and I think some people are
we we've got to recognize everybody has
that ability it's just we got to connect
with the right button there and we can't
have the expectation that we had when my
wife was going to college she was told
by a father her father you can either
become a nurse or you can go off and be
a PE teacher her brother electrical
engineer
and so
Margaret wasn't given that option and I
would say she's the gifted one in the
family too and and certainly the best
looking one but uh I
I think that we got us you know
I as a kid was fearful of certain things
in school as element spelling I hated it
and you know to the point where I got
myself sick several times over having to
be called on by the teacher
and there are a lot of kids like that
fear and and uh of making a mistake
so so I think it's a lot to do with
instruction too not just the curriculum
side but the instruction side and the
the nature of the individual and a lot
of issues I I agree with both you on
this
I actually think that has something to
do with what you underlined on page 25
connecting it to Extended Learning
opportunities and your your great your
grandson who wants art if you could
realize how the art could be connected
how Math Connects to Art it might make
him want to learn it more because it
does you know spatial relations and and
all that so that has something to do
maybe that has something to do with how
he'll learn it if if it can if he can
realize that math does affect his art
classes yeah I think is what we need to
do we need to pursue this subject of
mathematics and work with some Math
teachers and and various organizations
trying to get some reporting back to us
to find out how can we as a legislature
help out on this
um
and not pointing any fingers or anything
like that but since we all recognize we
are at a point where we've got to do
something in the state
and so I'd like to maybe use this group
as a group where we can start chewing at
it
any further Becky I see you have a
handout in the audience
foreign
thank you
okay that I think takes us down to
we've done pretty much everything on
that docket today yeah I I just want to
comment on particularly on the item five
dealing with the Ed 306. okay I was uh
encouraged uh from Dr Green's uh
comments on this has been a very
controversial issue and there's been
um all kinds of charges of
um No Lack of transparency
Etc but based upon Dr Green's comments
this morning it appears that there is an
attempt to expand the input for that
which is all the
um various stakeholder groups are asking
for so it appears to me that prior to
any kind of a final report going to the
uh the State Board of Education that
those not only the advocate groups being
involved but also engaging Community
groups in seeking input on that too so I
was I was really pleased to hear that
well I think that's not what I've been
hearing I agree with you I think that
there's got to be transparency there's
got to be communication between all
groups and when I see the word like
competency and when I saw that initial
report came out and that word was being
challenged
acknowledgment of something uh something
such as that
um
it that that's a lot of statutory
changes that are going on here and and
uh a lot of changes which are going to
impact everything we do in education in
the state if if we can make changes
which are positive and going to result
in the positive and I'm all for it but
let's do it in uh that you know like 21
incest where we have to do an open
shared way working with all parties
including students parents school board
members teachers principals community
community leaders all have to be
involved with this
um yes representative luno yeah thanks
Rick I I completely agree with that and
and what what what Mel just um just said
um said as well uh that I think um Dr
Green was uh was was very helpful in in
saying that uh that the uh that draft uh
set of rules would be available by the
end of the week we can get that out and
begin the the comment period but I think
where I do have a concern and I I hope
you know this would be shared with with
the members in the committee as well
that that
um
you know it's not going to be 45 days
from Friday that um that the department
plans to take those Draft rules to the
State Board of Education and I don't
know how in 45 days they're going to be
able to convene the um the public
feedback groups
um as well as as get feedback from from
this committee uh relative to the um the
Draft rules and then be able to
incorporate that feedback and do all
that and do all that in time to uh to
present an early March to the uh to the
state board so so you know I would I
would you know respectfully suggest that
maybe the department reconsider it's uh
its time frame in in bringing these
rules to um uh to the board to provide
uh public stakeholders as well as this
committee uh I think a reasonable amount
of time uh obviously in consideration
nation of you know we're we're not just
all sitting on our hands waiting for
this report to drop got a few other
things to do right Rick yes we did and
uh
um you know before bringing it to the
state board I I think that might be a
reasonable request from from this
committee
I was very impressed with uh Nate green
Dr Green I've met with him
three times or so within the last month
over there at doe he's very open wanting
to work with us and he's underneath the
auspices of Caitlyn Davis who expressed
the same desire so I I
I I I'm I'm just going to wait and see
what kind of process they present I
think they've gotten the message
that we're going to have to all be part
of this and uh nobody's going to take
anything you know thrown at us it's got
to be able to stick and and um so just
because I I remain hopeful yeah just a
couple of comments on the you mentioned
earlier uh in your comments around
students I do hope that they're seeking
student input and the reason why I say
that I think students bring to the table
a much different perspective to their
learning styles and needs than what we
give them credit for
um I if you look at the availability of
information
that that's there now
they have that information they they
have that information right here right
and so the question is is how do you
translate the information they can get
here
versus a learning style
within schools yeah and I think it's a
heck of a challenge to try to do it so I
hope that they will seek student input
the other thing I think it's important
to note too
that any changes that come out of the
State Board of Education has to come
back to this committee
the legislative oversight committee
looks at all that stuff that's going to
be dealt with at the State Board of
Education so I think the issue of the
inclusive approach
to getting the data to getting the
information there before it becomes
finalized before it goes before the
rules committee and I think that's very
important
that that input is there before the
rules committee because once it gets the
rules committee it's awfully hard to
change it's just not input from us it's
our recommendation right exactly and so
that that that's a real concern and I
agree with you on that Junior High kids
I I just have to get my junior high
grandson down to help me pair this thing
to my car
um it's a new one and it's pairing to
the old one and I sit there just
frustrated coming down the highway
wanting to talk somebody and
can't do it
so that younger generation is a good
generation but I'd also talk to the kids
that are in the community college system
and and and those have just recently
graduated find out what was their
experience like while they were in the
grade school through the 12th grade in
terms of mathematics and that feedback's
good feedback
anything further today I know that
Senator ward has to get out of here she
has another meeting coming up
um
is there any comments from the public
yeah we're I'm open to that
um we're going to adjourn here in a
minute but if they're what we're seeing
now is that we want to get a hold of the
cohort information we want to get the at
the the report that's coming back from
the contracted service for looking at
our assessment tests in terms of
improvement and following individual
classes all the way through we're
interested in looking at this this very
much in the area of social studies and
finding out what's going on at the local
level and we're also wanting to delve
into the area of mathematics and and
maybe using this math task force Report
with some of those wonderful
recommendations over 20 some odd
recommendations in that I don't think we
should leave it alone even though
there's a lot new research out there
there's good stuff there for us to look
at
so those are the three takeaways I can
take from this weaning right now and
also waiting for that big report to come
in that we're all waiting for in terms
of the the normal standards for public
school approval that's very important
um so with that anything from the public
not seeing any hands flying everybody
wants lunch thank you very much all for
attending today and the next meeting
will be we'll call the chair
okay
well
if we do it it's going to have to be on
like um let's see today's a Tuesday
right
right oh that's right so we'd have to be
after okay we'd have to talk to those
folks too
um I I think it'd be great for us to
have uh if we can get a regular schedule
going
um I'll I'll talk with everybody here on
the web and find out what days are good
um we know that we saw at least 16 bills
of which have been withdrawn lsrs for
this committee so we may be down to
around 100 now
and and that's still overload uh and so
we're gonna have to and I I gotta find
out which ones have physical notes
because they're going to be the first
ones out and that's going to take some
time hearing and executing sessions so
I'm going to try and stay away from
Mondays like I told the community so
people have doctor's appointments Etc
you can do that
um what day does the education committee
meet Senator Ward Tuesday Morning
Tuesday morning so
there's there's another time too that as
bills start leaving here and Bill's
Governor we are in both places at the
same time
so we have to work on that as well so
I'll get back to everybody and try and
find a day so yes I I don't want this to
SL you know they say we should be
meeting at least quarterly I think we
need to meet more than quarterly I think
we need to be meeting and getting on
these topics here and not let them hang
and then disappear when we disappear
stay on it
any further
thank you very much have a good one yep
thank you